[Musique]
dans l'actualité ce soir cette nouvelle
catastrophe aérienne cette fois dans
l'océan indien un airbus a310 de la
yemenia airways s'est écrasé après avoir
tenté un atterrissage aux comores il y
avait 153 personnes à bord dont 66
français avaient embarqué à paris ou
marseille
une seule rescapée une adolescente de 14
ans a été retrouvée vivante flottant
dans l'eau selon les sauveteurs
ce soir les proches des victimes sont en
colère ils dénoncent depuis des années
les conditions de vol l'avion en
question était interdit sur le sol
français suit temps à contrôler on a
appris que la compagnie était l'objet
d'une enquête de l'union européenne
depuis deux ans dans le reste de
l'actualité la prison à perpétuité avec
22 ans de sûreté c'est la peine requise
contre youssouf fofana devant la cour
d'assises de paris
une couverture qui en feu sans doute à
cause d'une cigarette mal éteinte un
incendie en pleine ville à asnières a
fait six morts dans un immeuble à
caractère social une page se tourne en
irak s'est fait les troupes américaines
ont quitté les grandes villes les forces
irakiennes ont pris le relais le premier
ministre maliki évoque un jour de fête
enfin l' enquête qui donne à espérer la
pollution des côtes françaises marquent
le pas la mère retrouve ses couleurs et
on verra que certaines espèces disparues
comme les hippocampes refont leur
apparition
c'est le dossier de cette édition
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous l'océan
atlantique il y à un mois
l'océan indien aujourd'hui c'est donc
une nouvelle catastrophe aérienne qui a
endeuillé la france la nuit dernière
l'appareil effectuait la dernière partie
d'un vol paris marseille sanaa moroni
il s'est abîmé en mer alors qu'il
préparait son atterrissage amaury
guibert avec des moyens de fortune les
secours comoriens se prépare à rejoindre
la zone du crash un bateau pneumatique
hors d'âge
quelques hommes à son bord mais au large
une mer démontée
plus tôt dans la matinée un pilote d'une
compagnie locale avait pu survoler la
zone de l'accident
ce week-end avait nautiques environ 40
km j'ai retrouvé des traces
d'hydrocarbures et une deuxième phrase
de plusieurs débris pour ce vol 626 au
départ de paris la yemenia avait affecté
deux avions d'abord un airbus a330 dans
lequel embarque 67 personnes d'école
ge à 10 heures hier matin direction
marseille c'est la première escale à
l'aéroport de marignane 78 passagers
supplémentaires en barque avec 145
personnes à bord l'avion met le cap sur
la capitale du yémen sanaa c'est la
deuxième escale du vol 626 une
correspondance avec changement
d'appareil 153 personnes dont 66
français prennent pas leur place à bord
d'un airbus a 310 7 avions beaucoup
moins récents le voici
il prend la direction de moroni la
capitale des comores
mais disparaît des écrans radar à 00h50
heure de paris a annoncé salut des
défuntes
il était un contact avec le contrôleur
avant l'atterrissage ce soir les
familles se pressent devant l'aéroport
de moroni dans l'espoir que leurs
proches et survécu mais pour l'heure
seule une adolescente de 14 ans a été
retrouvée en vie une course contre la
montre s'engage et la france y participe
elle a envoyé deux bâtiments de la
marine et un avion militaire avec 6
tonne de matériel et des secouristes
certains sont d'ailleurs déjà intervenue
aux comores
c'était en 1996 images impressionnantes
de cet airbus éthiopien détournés par
des pirates de l'air et s'abîmant près
des côtes
55 des 177 passagers avaient alors
survécu une seule rescapée donc sans
doute selon nos confrères d'europe 1
l'adolescente voyage est avec sa mère on
écoute l'un de ceux qu'il a sauvée elle
tremblait de froid
écoutez il faut tendre un peu l'oreille
elle est en bonne santé c'est ça que
vous nous dites oui on allait donner de
l'eau chaude que commencer à nous
répondre à ta question
on a lui demandé seulement le nom le
village
on va lui amener à l'hôpital urgent une
seule survivante donc elle a 14 ans la
plupart des passagers sont d'origine
comorienne français d'origine comorienne
on l'a entendu ils avaient embarqué à
marseille et sur place les proches des
voyageurs ne sont pas seulement
bouleversé
c'est ils sont aussi en colère nous
avions prévenu distille sur place
isabelle staes christophe la rocca une
jeune fille désormais orpheline elle
vient d'apprendre que les membres de sa
famille étaient tous dans l'avion
jusqu'au bout ils ont gardé l'espoir que
leurs proches n'avait pas embarqué sur
le vol qui reliait le yémen au comores
[Musique]
c'est un disque qu'on l'attendait ce fut
longtemps et maintenant c'est
78 personnes d'origine comorienne
avaient embarqué hier à marseille
beaucoup de familles qui retournait au
pays pour les vacances c'est toute la
communauté comorienne jeunes moins
jeunes qui est touché on a tous perdu
quelqu'un dans ce rôle qui soit proche
ou moins proche nes et des membres de
leur famille à la douleur succès de la
colère il aura fallu plus de dix heures
d'attentes à l'aéroport pour obtenir la
liste des passagers de la part de la
compagnie yéménite dit cette personne
n'avait pas embarqué au yémen pour les
comores faute de place comment puis-je
con las bonne idée de vous dire votre
proche a disparu c'est impensable
je ne peux pas prendre ce serait
insupportable je peux pas les mêmes
termes et maintenant donnez moi cette
[ __ ] de liste inglin comme ça depuis
des années la communauté comorienne
dénoncé en vain les risques d'une
catastrophe
c'est dans l'avion sa peur la peur parce
que on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix c'est toujours le même bazar et on
nous prend 1,10 et on nous amène à sanaa
après sa non ya pas d'informatique à
rien c'est c'est c'est l'anarchie comme
on dit chacun fait ce qu'il veut
on comprend bon toi tu montes toi tu
montres que tu montes pas après demain
je rentre à linge une semaine tu restes
on est traité comme du bétail comme
d'habitude on est des comoriens à
marseille
le prochain vol à destination du yémen
est prévue jeudi pas question pour ces
comoriens de le laisser partir
il faut rappeler que les comores compte
quelques 800 mille habitants et ne
possède pas de ce fait une compagnie
aérienne internationale
bonsoir nassurdine haydari vous êtes en
direct à marseille vous êtes l'un des
visages connus de cette communauté
nombreuse qui compte 80 mille membres à
marseille
vous êtes aussi conseiller
d'arrondissement quelles réponses
aviez-vous reçu lorsque vous aviez
attirer l'attention sur ses conditions
de vol cela fait six mois que l'on
dénonce aujourd'hui la situation de
sanaa c'est des femmes qui se font
tabasser lorsqu'elles disent que c'est
votre ces avions sont des cargos
poubelle on ne peut pas voyager dans de
telles conditions et nous avons
interpellé toutes les autorités
compétentes
nous sommes même allés au yémen sont
même allés aux comores nous avons
interpellé tous les responsables
politiques de ce pays pour dire
attention il ya un drame qui se prépare
est aujourd'hui ce drame là où
et là nous avons plus de 150 âmes
aujourd'hui que nous avons perdu nous
sommes en colère la communauté
comorienne est en colère nous ne pouvons
pas aujourd'hui rester dans cette
situation
dominique bussereau ne peut pas nous
dire aujourd'hui que l'a310 ne peut pas
aujourd'hui relier marseille sanaa mais
peut relier un a310 peut relier moroni
sanaa non nous sommes des citoyens
français comme les autres il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de gestion différentiel
wings un temps aujourd'hui lésés par
cette situation
dominique bussereau secrétaire d'état
aux transports on l'entendra dans un
instant qu est ce qui vous permet de
penser précisément du point de vue de la
sécurité et sur ce que vous avez vu lors
des précédents voyages qu'il y avait les
problèmes qui pouvaient mettre en cause
la vie des passagers
c'est à dire quand vous arrivez à sanaa
vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez pas de
ceinture de ces cas de sécurité vous
n'avez pas de clim n'y a pas de
climatisation danser dans ses avions
et quand on n'a même pas le droit de
dire vous voyez il y a un problème parce
qu'on se fait tabasser
vous comprenez bien que tout le monde
savait qu'il y avait aujourd'hui un
problème
et moi je parle de crime organisé
aujourd'hui c'est on est enfin on est
aujourd'hui devant le silence français
l'incompétence aujourd'hui du yémen et
malheureusement aujourd'hui
l'incompétence des comores c'est un
crime c'est un crime organisé et la
communauté comorienne toute la
communauté comorienne est dans l'effroi
med est aussi dans la colère merci
monsieur haïdari d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce soir alors précisément on
va en venir aux éléments dont on dispose
sur cet avion d'une part sur la
compagnie d'autre part on fait le point
avec jérôme berfa et pascal caron voici
l'a310 de yemenia airways il y à peu sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport de moroni sur
cet avion de nombreuses questions se
posent aujourd'hui est d'abord celle de
son état il était en activité depuis 19
ans 52 mille heures de vol au compteur
soit les deux tiers de sa durée de vie
c'est un ancien avion d'air france
mais en 2007 la direction de l'aviation
civile constate de nombreux défauts plus
problème de type 3 les plus graves
possible depuis il était interdit de vol
en france
dans l'état où ils étaient la france
effet dû remarquer donc il fallait les
corriger je suppose que comme elles
n'ont pas été corrigés comme par hasard
l'avion n'est pas revenu mais selon les
autorités yéménites
l'a310 avait été totalement inspecté en
mai dernier sous la supervision de
spécialistes d'airbus
deux cent trente airbus a310 vole
toujours à travers la planète dont
quatre pour yemenia jusqu'à ce matin
l'avionneur européen a lancé une enquête
notre cellule de crise est en relation
avec la compagnie elle est en relation
avec les autorités mais naturellement
nous allons tenter de rapporter toutes
les informations dont ils ont besoin
vient alors la question de la compagnie
sans incident majeur depuis dix ans yves
héniart était pourtant sous surveillance
dans l'union européenne pour manquements
à certaines normes de sécurité
mais en avril dernier la commission a
constaté des améliorations
ce n'est pas l'avis de certains
passagers l'an dernier à marseille
ils manifestaient contre ce qu'ils
appellent des avions poubelles
aujourd'hui la compagnie affirme que
tous ces avions sont aux normes et
vérifier nous sommes désolés pour toutes
les familles pour ce qui s'est passé
mais vous savez ce sont des choses qui
arrivent pas seulement à nouméa tous les
transporte pour vous la seule
explication c'est la météo
c'est la seule possible à ce stade où
les conditions météo justement voici ce
qu'indique la carte de météo france au
moment du drame près de l'aéroport peu
de nuages pas d'orage mais du vent 60 km
heure et des rafales pas énorme d'après
les spécialistes de météo france
mais peut-être assez pour gêner la
proche d'un avion cette deuxième
catastrophe en un mois intervient en
tout cas la veille des vacances c'est
l'occasion de rappeler que l'avion reste
l'un des moyens de transport les plus
fiables
ça n'empêche pas l'union européenne on
l'a entendu il ya un instant d'établir
une liste noire des compagnies les moins
sûrs florence ma vie crée des risques de
la rue en 2006 deux ans après la
catastrophe de charm el cheikh qui fit
148 morts l'union européenne publie sa
première liste noire celle des
compagnies interdites de séjour sur son
territoire
aujourd'hui on en recense 200 des
compagnies souvent
microscopique pour l'essentiel basé en
afrique en asie et dans les pays de
l'est
comment décide-t-on de mettre au banc
une compagnie les instances
internationales de l'aviation civile
recense les incidents dont elle est
victime
et dans chaque pays des inspecteurs
contrôler les avions en transit système
de sécurité réacteurs étanchéité du
réservoir
en france 700 inspections sont conduites
chaque année dans les aéroports ces
contrôles restent purement visuel et ce
n'est pas tout la flotte d'une compagnie
qui sera inspecté lorsque vous touriste
que vous allez partir de france et vous
allez vous retrouver sur des lignes
intérieures africaine sud-américaine en
inde et en asie du sud-est gras vous
allez vous retrouver à voler sur des
avions qui paie au rythme de verre
étaient en liste noire et qui ne sont
pas parce que les quelques bons et bien
de la compagnie je retrouve à voler à
roissy l'avion reste cependant un moyen
de transport fiable le risque
d'accidents mortels et 25 fois moins
élevé qu'en voiture
à l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
observé un instant de recueillement à la
mémoire des victimes jeudi prochain
c'est à dire après demain nicolas
sarkozy assistera à une cérémonie
inter-religieuse dommages à la grande
mosquée de paris
par ailleurs une messe sera célébrée à
leur intention à l'intention des
victimes à notre dame de paris
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur ce
nouveau drame autres titres de
l'actualité que s'est il passé à
asnières ce matin comment un incendie
dans une chambre ou un appartement at il
pu provoquer la mort de six personnes
le feu est parti du 1er étage dans un
immeuble à caractère social arnaud
compte david fossard
les habitants ont été piégés dans leur
sommeil le feu s'est propagé en quelques
minutes à tout l'immeuble
paniqués les locataires se réfugie alors
sur le toit et au foehn et m'apporte
commencé à brûler donc je ne me réfugie
dans la pile au fond donc c'était je
suis passé par la fenêtre j'ai été chez
le voisin
après ça on en est un michel et avec les
chefs chaussée ce sont des voisins
réveillés par l'alarmé incendie qui ont
donné l'alerté vers 6h30 une personne
seront fournis strauss incarna vous
voyez là haut on tombait une femme a pu
s'extraire par al par des draps nouveau
du troisième trois personnes ont péri en
sautant par les fenêtres
trois autres piégés par les flammes onze
résidents sont ce soir hospitalisés dont
un dans un état grave
le feu aurait pris dans une chambre
première étape le feu aurait pu naître à
la suite d'une couverture qui se serait
embrasé peut être dû à un mégot mais
tout cela est à vérifier en fonction
notamment des explications de la
personne qui se trouve actuellement en
garde à vue pour ces faits l'immeuble un
hôtel meublé à vocation sociale avait
été contrôlé en 2005 et 2007
les essais incendie pratiques qui
avaient été concluants dans l'actualité
également la justice avec un procès qui
touche à sa fin celui du gang des
barbares et de youssouf fofana en
particulier bonsoir dominique verdeilhan
vous êtes en direct devant la cour
d'assises de paris en fin d'après midi
l'avocat général a requis la peine
maximum contre youssouf fofana
oui le paradoxe de ce réquisitoire c'est
qu'il a plutôt été bien accueillie par
la défense et a provoqué la colère de la
partie civile vous l'avez dit philippe
bilger l'avocat général a requis la
peine maximale perpétuité avec une
période de sûreté de 22 ans il est
provocation il est anti sémitisme selon
les dires du magistrat mais celui-ci
surtout a voulu faire le distinguo entre
celui qui aurait assassiné ilan halimi
et ceux qui ont participé à son
enlèvement et sa séquestration
les zapa les geôliers en conséquence il
a requis des peines allant de 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle à 5 ans pour les
faits criminels pour la famille halimi
ce fut donc la consternation la colère
madame halimi va pouvoir croiser dans
quelques années ceux qui ont participé
aux martyrs de son fils nous disait il
ya quelques minutes m
francis szpiner j'avoue propose à
l'écouté nous ne comprenons pas que dans
une affaire comme celle-ci qui a ému à
juste titre notre pays
il y à une telle faiblesse de celui qui
est en charge de porter l'accusation et
tous les hommages rendus par l'avocat
général à la partie civile des avocats
ne change rien
c'est avec beaucoup de déception
beaucoup d'amertume commun havas libye
et ses enfants ou entendu ce
réquisitoire
dominique voilà encore une fois ce ne
sont que les réquisitions le verdict lui
est attendu pour le 11 juillet le samedi
11 dominique verdeilhan à paris merci à
vous dominique l'actualité sociale avec
une étude qui va sans doute faire
grincer des dents elle a été réalisée
par un cabinet d'audit externe à
l'éducation nationale elle montre que
les instituteurs sont en moyenne deux
fois plus nombreux à poser des congés
maladie que les salariés du privé
un constat relativiser par le ministre
luc chatel mallory yahoo nous jean
francois monier
yat-il bien un prof dans la classe
l'étude qui fâchent révèle que sur
l'année scolaire 2007 2008 45 % des
professeurs des écoles ont posé un congé
maladie
deux fois plus que chez les salariés du
privé est forcément un enseignant absent
c'est une trentaine de familles très
occupé l'airé dernière une véritable
catastrophe en cp dont il ya une année
importante en salles contre on a eu une
succession de huit professeurs
et non la maîtresse au bout de trois
mois faut comprendre aussi que sur
l'année 1 million 500 mille journées de
cours auraient ainsi été perdus surtout
entre novembre et février saison du
virus mais aussi lors du mois de mai et
cpo pourtant le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation temporise on peut être en
formation on peut être en journée
pédagogique
ensuite un enseignant qui tous les jours
vous à 25 ou 30 élèves qui eux mêmes
voient des centaines d'élèves
il a plus de chances de tomber malade
que quelqu'un qui travaille toute sa vie
dans un bureau certes les professeurs
s'arrête en moyenne 11 jours par an de
plus que les salariés du privé mais dans
la fonction publique les policiers sont
malades 19 jours les agents de la
défense de la justice ou de l'équipement
au moins quinze jours et ce n'est pas
tout 80 % des professeurs des écoles
sont des femmes
donc on a forcément dans notre métier
beaucoup plus d'absences pour congé de
maternité plus que du nombre d'absences
les parents s'inquiètent donc surtout de
la continuité du service public
lorsqu'un prof est absent huit jours il
est rarement remplacer voir qu'un jour
il est rarement remplacer c'est
forcément une perte parce que ces zones
sont pas récupérés sur dix jours
d'absence seuls s'ils sont réellement
remplacer faute de personnel
d'organisation aussi de quoi légitimer
la création d'une agence nationale des
remplacements
elle pourrait fonctionner dès la
prochaine rentrée et cette étude n'a
toujours pas été dévoilée officiellement
en bref une pensée pour les plus jeunes
les collégiens de classes de troisièmes
ils étaient près de 780 mille a débuté
aujourd'hui les épreuves du brevet
français histoire-géographie et
éducation physique aujourd'hui demain
viendront les mathématiques courage l'an
dernier 80 2 % des élèves ont obtenu ce
premier diplôme
jour j moins un pour tous les
restaurants et les bars de france et
demain que la baisse de la tva devient
effective
on passe vous le savez de 19,6 à cinq et
demi pour cent c'est un gros
investissement public 2 à 3 milliards
d'euros pour l'état
la diminution des prix et les embauches
seront elles au rendez vous quels sont
les engagements pris petit tour
d'horizon avec julien beaumont et
guillaume michel
un jour près ce client aurait pu
économiser 2 euros sur ce plat car
demain ce restaurant impliquera la
baisse de la tva sur certains produits
mais à qui va profiter ce cadeau de
l'état malki jour en jeu et obtenir en
profiteront pour dire ben la cc c'est
tout bénef pour nous quoi le patron de
cette chaîne de restaurants va baisser
les prix dans 600 établissements
il espère néanmoins une hausse de son
chiffre d'affaires on attend ce que les
clients soient consomment davantage nos
clients fidèles vont prendre un deuxième
café vont prendre un dessert quand il
n'en prenaient pas vont prendre un verre
de vin quand il n'en prenait peut-être
pas seuls les établissements affichant
ce logo s'engagent à baisser au minimum
sept plats mais pas l'alcool la tva à 19
6 % ayant été maintenue des changements
qu'ils ne se feront que sur la base du
volontariat
justement dans ce bouchon lyonnais pas
de ristourne au menu robert dufault a
décidé de ne pas modifier ses prix
impossible aussi pour lui d'embauché
j'avais besoin
on n'a pas bougé nos prix la marchandise
a augmenté tout a augmenté mais on peut
pas se permettre
ou alors ce serait être un peu mesquin
diront bachelot prix puissions basse les
portions sert à rien en attendant c'est
l'état qui paye l'addition
le manque à gagner est évalué à 2,3
milliards d'euros des relevés de prix
auront lieu pour vérifier que les
restaurateurs signataires jouent le jeu
en échange la profession s'est engagée à
créer 40 mille emplois d'ici 2011
cette baisse de la tva c'était une des
promesses de campagne de jacques chirac
il aura fallu sept ans pour obtenir son
entrée en vigueur
et on y reviendra en détail demain avec
des cas précis avec les prix pour voir
si les promesses sont tenues
l'actualité à l'étranger c'est
décidément la journée des catastrophes
un train transportant du carburant gpl a
déraillé puis explosé en pleine ville en
italie il y à 14 morts et autant de
blessés dans un état grave
correspondance philippe visseyrias il
est minuit un déluge de feu vient de
s'abattre sur viareggio
le long de la voie ferrée maisons et
voitures sont en flammes à 200 mètres de
la gare un wagon-citerne chargé de gpl a
déraillé
le gaz s'est répandu dans tout le
quartier le transformant en brasier
chez moi je suis devant ma porte
j'ai vu un homme qui brûlait comme une
torche à l'explosion a soufflé plusieurs
maisons les pompiers fouillent les
décombres
les blessés souvent gravement brûlés
sont évacués
soudain au milieu des ruines une main un
jeune garçon est retrouvé indemne après
une nuit de cauchemar viareggio essaie
de comprendre sur la voie ferrée le
wagon qui a pris feu et isolée du reste
du convoi
apparemment le train roulait trop vite
dans l'après midi
silvio berlusconi s'est rendu sur place
les autorités ont promis une enquête
pour déterminer les causes de l'accident
à l'hôpital
le bilan s'alourdit d'heure en heure et
la main d'un quiz ma mère est en train
de mourir on m'a dit de venir la voir
une dernière fois
mon père lui est dans un autre hôpital
et
n'est pas comment il va à viareggio tout
le monde se demande pourquoi un tel
chargement de gaz inflammables étaient
autorisés à circuler aussi près des
habitations
une page se tourne en irak s'est fait
les troupes américaines ont quitté les
grandes villes les forces irakiennes ont
pris le relais et le premier ministre
maliki évoqué aujourd'hui un jour de
fête pour tous les irakiens sherrard
respecte l'armée irakienne est de retour
sur le devant de la scène
moment historique puisque le 30 juin va
devenir un jour férié
il marquera la souveraineté retrouvée ou
presque
les forces américaines ont quitté les
grandes villes hier elles ont patrouillé
une dernière fois puis les soldats
américains ont été consignées sur leur
base à la périphérie pour l'amérique le
désengagement a commencé la police
irakienne s'en réjouit je suis très
confiant dans la capacité de nos forces
pour maintenir l'ordre et la sécurité
et toute la journée bagdad a connu les
mêmes scènes de joie à bassorah dans le
sud du pays des soldats rebord même la
fleur au fusil
l'armée irakienne dissoute par les
américains en 2003 puis reformé et
équipé par les mêmes américain a pris
position sur les grands axes routiers
nous rêvions d'un jour pareil mais nous
l'espérions sans trop y croire vraiment
et c'est enfin
c'est donc la première étape d'un
désengagement américain voulu par barack
obama
aujourd'hui les villes dans deux ans le
pays à condition que l'armée irakienne
soit capable d'assurer la sécurité ce
qui ne semble pas encore être le cas
aujourd'hui à kirkouk un attentat à la
voiture piégée a fait plus de 20 morts
et ces derniers jours les violences se
sont multipliées jusqu'au coeur de
bagdad où mercredi dernier 62 personnes
ont été tuées et puis cette information
cinq jours après la mort de michael
jackson on a appris il ya quelques
minutes que son corps sera transporté
après demain dans son ranch californien
de neverland à de los angeles
il y sera exposé publiquement vendredi
autrement dit ceux qui souhaitent ceux
qui le souhaitent pourront venir se
recueillir
c'est ce qu'annonce en tout cas cnn la
chaîne d'informations en continu ajoute
qu'une cérémonie privée réservée à la
famille devrait être ensuite organisé
dimanche on va retrouver alain de
chalvron en direct de los angeles avant
la fin de ce journal
il est 20 heures 22 rester avec nous à
suivre la fin d'un casse tête il y aura
bientôt un chargeur de téléphone
portable unique pour tous les modèles un
accord a été trouvé à bruxelles des
raisons d'espérer pour la grande bleue
la pollution des côtes marque le pas
mais on verra qu'il ya encore beaucoup à
faire c'est le dossier de cette édition
enfin la mort d'un des grands noms de la
danse contemporaine la chorégraphe pina
bausch avait 68 ans d'abord donc qui a
dit que l'europe nous compliquer la vie
la commission a trouvé un terrain
d'entente avec les principaux fabricants
de téléphones portables un chargeur
universel compatible avec toutes les
marques va faire son apparition l'an
prochain gilles marine est bernie
mériaux prenez au hasard une
demi-douzaine de téléphone et vous aurez
autant de charger chacun d'eux est
destiné un appareil spécifique
impossible de l'utiliser pour un autre
mobile
tout jamais les mêmes et on chérit son
portable en émission
la commission européenne vient donc
d'obtenir des fabricants la création
d'un chargeur universel tous les mobiles
seront équipés de la même connexion à
partir de 2010 tous les mobiles sont
livrés qu'un chargeur qui est identique
l'étape d'après c'est les mobiles sont
livrés sans charger puisque on a pas
besoin de changer de chargeur à chaque
fois ça sait pas encore à qui on y
travaille avec les constructeurs des
constructeurs qui devront bientôt
renoncer au bénéfice de vendre
systématiquement un chargeur pour un
mobile en revanche pour bénéficier du
chargeur compatible et durable les
consommateurs eux devront investir dans
un nouveau téléphone l'environnement ne
cherchait plus les ampoules à filament
de 100 watts ou plus dans les magasins
dès demain elles vont disparaître du
commerce pour laisser place aux ampoules
dites de basse consommation ce sera
ensuite le cas pour les 75 puis 60 et 40
watts
toujours à propos d'environnement cette
enquête qui montre que tout n'est pas
noir en matière de protection de la
nature
elle concerne la mer et les côtes oui la
pollution régresse les hippocampes
reviennent mais le passif est lourd
vous allez découvrir à quoi ressemble
les fonds marins à quelques encablures
des côtes
lavez la mer c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé agnès monte et
bruno vignais au large de marseille
c'est une étrange à ce qui se prépare à
bord une cage et une poignée de
biologistes prêt à s'attaquer à l'un des
principaux fléaux des mères
pour faire une opération nettoyage on va
essayer de retirer un maximum de déchets
de la zone 5 mètres plus bas
voici ce qu'il découvre des fonds j'en
chie d'ordures sacs plastiques canettes
bouteilles de noeux un possible de tout
nettoyer
le but montrer exhiber ses décharges
enfouis cachée de nos regards pour
alerter l'opinion
seule une toute petite partie de ces
déchets est remonté à leur sortie les
scientifiques nous montrent leur prise
tout seul ses joies tu les appelles de
remords
ça c'est une bouteille en plastique doit
avoir
un vent qui a commencé pour dégager qui
a commencé à se déformer et on peut
espérer que d'ici 140 ou 150 ans il
aspire des confettis
voyez par les vagues ces confettis
pourront finir sur les plages 70% des
déchets ramassés sont justement en
plastique des petits déchets devenu
parfois invisible qui se mêlent aux
sables et aux cailloux toxiques ils
polluent durablement les sols et les
océans en plein coeur du pacifique au
large d'hawaï une association et tu lis
les petits éléments présents dans l'eau
surprise il y à une proportion énorme de
débris plastiques
oh non ici on a trouvé des prélèvements
où il y avait 40 fois plus de plastique
de plancton et celui là mon avis une
proportion d'environ 5 points par le jeu
des courants les déchets des américains
et des japonais ont été broyés concentré
dans cette zone isolée formant une soupe
de plastique les animaux comme les
oiseaux en sont les premières victimes
autopsie de l'un d'entre eux c'est
probablement une des raisons pour
laquelle cet oiseau est immense et ça
y'a tellement de plastique
une situation extrême que nous ne
connaissons pas encore en france
paradoxe on y trouve même des zones où
la vie sous marine semble aller mieux
qu'il ya vingt ans non non c'est là bas
là bas c'est ce que constate ces
spécialistes qui planchent au large de
cannes sous l'eau il voit de plus en
plus de coquillages comme ses grandes
nacres protéger et parfois même quelques
hippocampe qui avait quasiment disparu
l'explication une eau de meilleure
qualité un peu plus épuré on aura moins
de contamination contamination biologie
contamination par le virus et ceara et
du coup certaines espèces progrès à
paraître ce que les stations d'épuration
de nous ont usés se sont beaucoup
améliorées elle rejette dans la mer ou
non - pour lui si vous avez loupé iarivo
la station c'est ce qui sort des egos
les histoires du domicile des habitants
autres l'arrivée de la station et la
sortie on a retiré 98% de la commission
autrefois le retirer 60 % on voit bien
la différence
un progrès qui ne doit pas masquer les
autres problèmes comme les rejets de
pesticides ou de nitrates toujours
présents dans nos eaux traitées et bien
sûr l'accumulation de nos déchets en
pleine mer de nouvelles menaces sur ces
milieux fragiles
voilà on revient maintenant sur l'une
des actualités de ce début de soirée le
calendrier et les modalités des hommages
qui vont être rendu à michael jackson
ont été communiqués bonsoir alain de
chalvron comme promis vous êtes en
direct à los angeles
oui alors est ce qui était prévu
exactement c'est en fait des obsèques
privées dans un lieu encore inconnu pour
dimanche mais le corps de michael
jackson va être transférée à santa
barbara jeudi et vendredi ce port sur ce
corps sera exposé à tous ceux qui
voudront venir dans le fameux ran si
cher à michael jackson que le ranch de
neverland donc hommage public vendredi
obsèques privées
le dimanche en outre autre information
on a retrouvé le fameux testament de
michael jackson michael jackson donne
toi ses enfants donne quelque chose
aussi à sa mère mais exclut son père de
son testament
merci alain pour ces dernières
informations il risque d'y avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de monde vendredi donc
dans le ranch de neverland pour cet os
pour cet hommage la disparition d'un des
grands noms de la danse contemporaine la
chorégraphe allemande pina bausch est
mort aujourd'hui les suites d'un cancer
foudroyant diagnostiqué il ya cinq jours
seulement
elle était mondialement connue pour son
style expressionniste disait ton qui
réunissait souvent le théâtre et la
danse elle avait aussi introduit sur
scène des skis des vélos des murs
à 68 ans elle respect c'est sans doute
bon signe une créatrice controversé
autres grands noms de la danse angelyn
presles jo cage l'un de ces spectacles
est présenté dans le cadre fastueux des
jardins du château de versailles c'est
une adaptation très libre de blanche
neige
nicolas lemarignier marie cazaux
miroir mon beau miroir dis moi s'il
existe un plus beau décor pour un
spectacle de danse le ballet d'angelin
preljocaj se produit ce soir sur le
bassin de neptune à versailles
oui c'est bien elle la méchante reine de
blanche neige le conte de grimm revisité
par le chorégraphe contemporain oublier
les sept nains version disney ici c'est
une histoire originelle cruel et sombre
comme l'épisode de la pomme empoisonnée
[Musique]
allez on enlève les costumes de jean
paul gaultier la musique de gustav
mahler et il reste la danse juste la
danse père cette sensation du dos qui
voit là échauffement sous le regard
aiguisé du chorégraphe s'attaquer un
compte aussi populaire ça n'a rien
d'évident moi je voulais absolument
faire aucune concession sur l'écriture
chorégraphique c'est-à-dire à aucun
moment il ya je pense de facilité de
pantomime quoi se dire que chaque partie
on pourrait l'extraire et la regarder
comme un objet chorégraphique qui
pourrait être abstrait et libertés a été
donnée aux danseurs de moderniser leurs
personnages et mon costume saxe le
toréador
donc en fait je nage ou latinos lovers à
fond et fait c'est plus sympa c'est plus
marrant fin au change un petit peu n'en
reste pas du tout
traditionnel
la défense abstraite angelin prejlocaj
voulait s'offrir une parenthèse féerique
et enchanter son blanche neige est déjà
un classique
et puis nos félicitations à line renaud
élevé au grade de grand officier de
l'ordre du mérite au cours d'une
cérémonie
cet après midi à l'elysée images signées
alain locascio avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres à cette nouvelle
catastrophe aérienne cette fois dans
l'océan indien un airbus a310 de la
yemenia airways s'est écrasé alors qu'il
approchait de l'atterrissage aux comores
il y avait 153 personnes à bord dont 66
français avaient embarqué à paris ou
marseille
une seule rescapée une adolescente de 14
ans a été trouvée vivante flottant dans
l'eau selon ces sauveteurs a entendu un
témoignage à ce sujet tout à l'heure
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko grand soleil grandes
chaleurs
20h35 vous avez rendez vous en terre
inconnue frédéric lopez emmène zazie
chez les korowai au coeur de la
papouasie occidentale rencontre très
riche et prouvant aussi vous le
découvrirez pour la chanteuse
à demain
[Musique]
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr pour
l'union